it is not about any one person if the voters
conclude that you're putting your own ego or
your own grudges ahead of what's good for the
country they're going to look elsewhere period
I'm ready for a generational change in my
party Rhonda Santos be a great president
Tim Scott make a great president Nikki
Haley make a great president Mike Pompeo
Mike Pence go down the list they're all in
my generation what if he's the nominee you'd
have to you wouldn't I think he's the only
Republic looking to lose Joe so going into
2024 the Republicans are going to be looking
for candidates who are focused on winning
not just making a point or settling a score what
is his vision for 2024 is it I'm back because
that's not a vision to me it needs to be more
than I'm back Trump needs to take a good look
in the mirror and he needs to take a good look in
the room and he needs to read the room accurately
all over the country there's a very high
correlation between Maga candidates and
big losses or at least dramatically
underperforming the Republicans
um bought the ticket and they're going to
take this ride again and what Donald Trump is
is signaling by his meltdown down in Mar-A-Lago
over the last 12 hours is that he's prepared to
burn it all down that they may be done with him
but he is not done with them I'm looking at the
rest of the team and you know who the leader
of the rest of the team is and the rest of
the team didn't do well tonight we're barely
if it looks like the Republicans will barely
take the house some of the trump-backed
candidates really struggled and some of
it had to do with the election denialism I
wrote an open letter to Donald Trump this
morning on my sub stack that sorry Kaylee
it says Please Mr President don't run again